[Music]
john joins us up next in st louis john
welcome to the show
hi guys thank you so much it's such a
pleasure to speak with you guys
absolutely how can we help yeah so
so yeah so dr john um you know this
question is primarily for you i just
want to thank you first off um you know
i read your book i think you're
absolutely fantastic um i find myself in
a little bit of a situation here um i'm
trying to find financial peace even
after following the baby steps
so
really quickly i'm 32 years old all
debts paid off including my home
however
i recently just had a transmission go
out in my car
and that same kind of panic and that
same fear that i had uh came right back
and the fact that i had to take that on
my fully funded emergency fund so i was
just kind of looking to kind of see what
your guys's guidance would be on how to
kind of help tackle that kind of that
fear and that anxiety even after
following baby steps that's a great
question man tell me about how money
worked when you were a kid
uh there was no discussion on money um i
lived in a very very
very uh poor household there was no
doubt about it um and so there was no
discussion of money uh started off out
of college um very very rough student
loans you name it i was just guided
guided in the wrong direction
and i got out of that cool
um and then are you married
i am married i have two kids you have
two kids okay uh what was your wife's
situation like
uh pretty much the same just uh well she
had she has a loving family absolutely
fantastic um she only had a little bit
of college debt and just a little bit of
credit card debt but that's been paying
off so she has a completely different
upbringing than mine was so i'm gonna
oversimplify this because we're just
having a few minutes on the on the radio
is that cool
yeah that's fine all right so let's take
your situation and you grew up in a
house where we don't talk about money
it's a
dark cloud over the house there's never
enough of it and there's a lot of stress
that even as a young kid you know
we don't have fill in the blank right
right
your body put a gps pin in that
right
it put a pin in it and said this is not
safe
and
so
you discovered this
let's say let's say you're 25. um you
discover the baby steps suddenly you get
a path out of this of this
i'm not safe i'm not safe i'm not safe
i'm not safe i don't have any control in
my life
and you get a path out
your brain still understands that a
money issue is not only a money issue
it's a relationship issue it's
catastrophic and it is just scanning its
environment 24 7 365 looking for the
next thing that might get you and it
remembers that money stuff gets you
and so
now you are free
and
you ever been on a boat
all day on a boat
nope never been all about okay if you're
on a boat and you're going fishing or
skiing
what you don't realize is the water is
kind of rocking all day and when you get
off that boat you stand on the shore and
it
it feels weird for a little bit because
your body has to get used to the world's
not moving underneath you anymore
and so the word i want to give you is
practice
you are safe and you know the math
problem your frontal lobe right the
front part of your brain knows that
you're safe
the part that doesn't is the part that's
been trying to keep you safe and keep
you alive since you're a little kid
and what we're going to do is we're
going to practice every time that alarm
system sounds oh no it's all coming down
you can stop
and take a big deep breath and hold it
for a second and exhale
and say we got emergency fund we're good
and we're just gonna practice it and
we're gonna practice it we're gonna
practice it here's what you have you
have an identity that says i'm poor
i have an identity that says i'm not
safe and what you have to do is lean
into and learn a new identity and we we
say all the time like
or if you just scroll instagram it'll
tell you just decide man you can just
decide but you gotta practice it right
like i'm gonna be a great basketball
player it doesn't mean i'm gonna wake up
tomorrow and be a great basketball
player i'm gonna lose 100 pounds cool
it's gonna take you nine months right so
you are gonna have to practice leaning
into this new identity and it's gonna be
consciously aware of those thoughts when
they take off on you write them down if
you want to if you want to up the annie
if you want to super up to annie commit
to your wife hey when both because she's
going to feel the same things when
either one of us has a
money thing set off our alarm system
let's commit to telling the other person
because the other person can then hold
our hands and say good thing we have an
emergency fund good thing we're safe
good thing now we are just paying
ourselves for whatever we want because
we have no payments you see what i'm
saying right right absolutely i want you
to i want you to hear me very clearly
you're not broken
you're not dysfunctional
you're not malfunctioning
okay
your brain is just trying to keep you
safe and what it needs to learn is i am
safe now is that cool
yes sir congrats hey absolutely you have
changed
an entire legacy you know that right
right
you're gonna watch your kids as they
have a different experience in their
home a different one than you and
um you're gonna it will heal you over
time in a pretty profound and beautiful
way so congratulations for changing
everything now you gotta
walk on the ground understanding that
it's not shaking underneath it anymore
way to go man beautifully said john yeah
those kids when dad's going hey kids
here's how money works we just had this
thing happen with the car and we had the
money to pay for it we don't have to
stress and wonder where that money is
going to come from the kids then learn
oh that's okay to talk about money and
the way to avoid having stress with
money is having it in the bank and not
having to rely on other people's money
so the lessons that can be learned from
this are awesome and i would encourage
john uh he sounds like he's a saver
because he's very worried it's not going
to be enough so i'd encourage him to
spend it on purpose like you said
practice practice spending money right
even though it's leaving your bank
account you have plenty of it and
practice giving yes because it'll give
you joy with money instead of money's
the thing i have to hold on to because
what if what if what if instead you're
practicing all three give save spend
that's what we talk about on the show
and it's a healthy practice hey george i
see people a lot whether it's leadership
whether it's parenting um i talked to
somebody on my show earlier today that
were that was
saying hey i think i lost my mother gene
now um because my my youngster is three
and she wants to sleep with me but i
need a nice sleep right
we constantly think that if we run up
against something we don't understand
that we're somehow got character issues
we're a failure we're a loser we suck
it's often i just don't have that skill
set i just don't know to do that i've
never been in a position to do this
right and so if you've never taken a
free throw with 15 000 people cheering
you on you don't know what that pressure
is like you know what i mean so be
really gracious with yourself i have
never been in a situation where i have a
transmission flow out of my car and it's
annoying not um catastrophic not i might
get hit by a dad who's had too many
drinks not but i fill in the blank right
so let's give ourselves some grace and
start practicing living into these new
identities man it's gonna be great yeah
i was just meeting with our research
team yesterday and they were unpacking
some of the data from our latest
personal finance study and it was
fascinating to see the direct quotes of
how people are feeling around money and
it was an interesting connection so
it was about 48 said i can't get ahead
with my finances that's how they were
feeling 45 said i feel ashamed of the
way i handled money in the past and
another chunk about a third said i wish
i was taught how to handle money well
and there's an interesting connection
there i feel like i'll never get ahead
because i feel shameful about how i've
spent in the past because i wasn't
taught how to handle money told me how
to yeah and so we you just need to
relearn
and practice
it doesn't have to stay this way yeah
but it starts with a decision going
i'm not going to be like my parents
sometimes it's the anti-mentor right
i don't want to be how my parents were
stressed out the first time i i
said yeah i'll uh i'll change my son's
diaper
i did not know how diapers worked that's
me being vulnerable america i didn't
know how they worked and i tried to put
one on and i think on yourself nope on
my on my son okay thank you for uh it
was not i did not do a good job it would
not have been an effective use of that
diaper um and now you're an expert i'm
i'm pretty good at it but my wife came
and said
oh um that's not gonna work and so i had
to practice i had to learn how to do it
right it wasn't because i'm the worst
ever and i'm a loser nah it's got
practice man and so many of those things
we just gotta practice just gotta get
ahead
i gotta change that mindset i'm somebody
who's gonna win with money i'm somebody
who's gonna get ahead with money so i
gotta practice those things that are
gonna make that happen
yeah and james clear talks about this in
atomic habits of you know values
identity based goals where you go i'm
the kind of person who blank that's
right and it changes the way you look at
money when you do that yeah like i call
the first one of the first callers
i am a kind of person who never borrows
money
so i'm not going to go into debt for
school or whatever the thing is yeah
that's huge